F
PARLIAMENT JOINS US EXCLUSIVELY
IN MOMENTS YOU DON'T MISS IT.
BUT FIRST PAYBACK TIME, THAT IS
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANKLE.
>> Laura: WATCHING THE
PLUMMETING APPROVAL RATING
CONTINUED TO SLIP IT CONTINUES
TO GO DOWN, AND DOWN.
IT'S LIKE WATCHING A GAME OF
LIMBO.
YOU KEEP WONDERING TO YOURSELF
HOW LOW CAN JOE GO?
A POLL GIVES US A SNAPSHOT IN
TIME AND IT'S UGLY FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
43% APPROVE NOW OF JOE BIDEN'S
JOB PERFORMANCE, 53% DISAPPROVE.
AMONG KEY DEMOGRAPHICS HE IS
UNDERWATER.
WOMEN, THEY'RE RUNNING AWAY FROM
THEM.
THEY ARE TOO, INDEPENDENTS
FORGET ABOUT THEM.
LOOK AT THOSE NUMBERS.
ON THE PANDEMIC, 39% APPROVE OF
WHAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING.
AT 57% DISAPPROVE.
SUPPORT FOR MASS MANDATES,
VACCINE MANDATES IT'S ALSO
DROPPING.
THEY ARE FOLLOWING SUIT.
SO TODAY AND THE PARENTS RIGHTS
HOT SPOTS COME OF LOUD COUNTY
VIRGINIA, THEY JUST ANNOUNCED
THAT MASKS WOULD BE OPTIONAL
STARTING NEXT WEEK.
THIS CAME JUST HOURS AFTER
GOVERNOR GLENN YOUNGKIN SIGNED A
NEW YOUNG REQUIRING SCHOOLS TO
GO MASK OPTIONAL'S BY MARCH 1ST.
SO EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK, THERE
ARE BAD OMENS FOR DEMOCRATS.
EVEN THEIR POLITICAL
HEAVYWEIGHTS ARE FEELING THE
HEAT.
LIKE ILLINOIS BILL AND HER
GOVERNOR JP.
HE WOULD JUST SLAP DOWN BY A
BIPARTISAN LIKE A LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE.
NOW THEY OBVIOUSLY SAW THE
WRITING ON THE WALL AFTER STATE
JUDGES ALREADY GRANTED IN PRL IN
FAVOR OF PARENTS FROM A HUNDRED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT OPPOSED
SCHOOL MASS MANDATES.
WHAT IS AMAZING ABOUT THIS AS HE
WAS TOTALLY UNFAZED.
HE IS STILL WEIGHING HIS
OPTIONS.
>> MASKS ARE THE BEST WAY TO
PRESERVE AND PERSON LEARNING AND
KEEP PEOPLE ON STAFF SAFE.
EVERYONE SHOULD FEEL COMFORTABLE
WEARING THEIR MASKS AND EITHER
WAY THE NEXT STEP IS TO HEAR
FROM THE --
>> Laura: MORE SHOCKING IS THE
REALIZATION THAT EVEN UBER
LEFT-WING SAN FRANCISCANS CAN BE
PUSHED TOO FAR.
ALL WAGED PARENTS ONE TO RECALL
THREE RADICAL SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS JUST LAST NIGHT.
THE WARNING SIDES FOR THE
DEMOCRATS ARE FLASHING RED.
PEOPLE WANT CHANGE.
THE SPORTS AND ENTERTAINMENT
TWO OF THE MOST POPULAR
FESTIVALS ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT
THEY ARE DITCHING ALL COVID
RULES.
NO VACCINE, NO MASK, NOT EVEN
NEGATIVE TESTS ARE TO BE
REQUIRED FOR ENTRY.
GOOD FOR THEM.
LOOKS BAD FOR THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
THAT THEY HAVE DONE THESE RULES
TO KEEP THEM IN POWER BY KEEPING
YOU SCARED.
DEMOCRATS HANDLING OF COVID
ISN'T THE ONLY THING THAT IS
DRAGGING THEM DOWN.
THEY ARE REPORTING TONIGHT THAT
PRIVATE PULLING FROM THE DCC
SHOWS THAT G.O.P. ATTACKS USING
ISSUES SUCH AS CRITICAL RACE
THEORY COMITY FROM THE POLICE,
AND OPEN BORDERS OF AMNESTY ARE
ALARMINGLY POTENT.
AND IF DEMOCRATS DON'T RESPOND
TO A REPUBLICAN'S ATTACK ON
THESE ISSUES THAN THE G.O.P.'S
LEAD ON THE GENERIC BALLOT JUMPS
FROM FOUR, TO 14 POINTS AND
SWING DISTRICTS.
14 POINTS, THAT WOULD MEAN A
COMPLETE WIPEOUT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN NOVEMBER.
BUT GET READY, I PROMISE YOU
THAT ONE BY ONE VULNERABLE
DEMOCRATS WILL ATTEMPT TO PIVOT
OR TO TURN THE PAGE, OR REFRAME
THE NARRATIVE.
THEY ARE GOING TO SAY THINGS
LIKE WE WERE ALWAYS PLANNING TO
DROP THE MASKS, WE WERE NEVER
REALLY FOR DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
WE THINK SOME PROSECUTORS ARE
SOME CLOSE ON CRIME.
WE RESPECT PARENTS RIGHTS TO
SPEAK OUT AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS.
I'M TELLING YOU TONIGHT, BELIEVE
NONE OF THEM.
IF THEY ARE LYING.
EVERY KEY DEMOCRAT ON THE HILL
EXCEPT FOR MAYBE --
THEY LINE UP WITH A LEFT ON MOST
MAJOR ISSUES.
I DON'T BELIEVE THESE SO-CALLED
MODERATES WHO ONLY SPEAK OUT FOR
IS THE RADICALS WHEN THERE
BACKED INTO A POLITICAL CORNER.
PEOPLE LIKE MONTANA'S WHO'S UP
FOR REELECTION THIS YEAR.
SPEAK WITH AN OUTFIT NATIONAL
BRAND I THINK IN RURAL AMERICA
IS TOXIC.
>> I DON'T THINK THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CAN BE THE
MAJORITY PARTY UNLESS WE START
LISTENING TO AMERICA A LOT MORE.
>> Laura: BOTH HIM ARE JUST AS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR PARTIES
LURCH TO THE LEFT AND
CHUCK SCHUMER.
WHERE WERE THEY WHEN THE SCHOOLS
ISSUED REALLY BLEW UP?
WERE THEY WERE BLM WAS
TERRORIZING OUR CITIES?
DID YOU SPEAR THEM SPEAK OUT
THEM?
SO THIS SUMMER WHEN DEMOCRATS
RETURNED TO THEIR HOME STATES
AND THEIR ARGUING THAT THEY ARE
COMMON SENSE POLICIES ARE WHAT
GOT US TO THE PANDEMIC AND BACK
TO NORMAL LIFE, JUST LAUGH IN
THEIR FACE RESPECT FULLY OF
COURSE.
THEY HAD LITERALLY NOTHING TO DO
WITH FREEING AMERICA.
WE FREE OURSELVES.
YOU SHOULD BE PROUD OF THAT, AND
BE GRATEFUL OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHO KNEW THAT EARLY ON WE HAD TO
REOPEN AND WE HAD TO ALL GO BACK
TO WORK AND GET BACK TO NORMAL.
AND WHAT WOULD ANY OF US HAVE
DONE WITHOUT THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS WHO THOUGHT THEMSELVES
FOR THE PEOPLE, THEY FOUGHT FOR
THEMSELVES, THEY DIDN'T FEEL
BOUND BY THE GOVERNANCE OF
UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS LIKE
TONY FAUCI.
MY DONALD TRUMP, AND THEY WERE
RELENTLESSLY ATTACKED FORD.
SO THIS IS A TIME TO BE PROUD OF
WHO WE ARE.
PARENTS, MOTHERS, FATHERS,
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE.
ALL PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
AND PROFESSIONS.
WE ARE AMERICANS AND WE KNOW OUR
RIGHTS.
WE EXPECT RESULTS FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO SWORE TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION.
WE WILL GIVE PEOPLE THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT FOR SURE.
BUT OUR PATIENTS HAS ITS LIMITS.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE PLAYED BY
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
SO STOP INSULTING OUR
INTELLIGENCE.
WE KNOW WHAT YOU DID, AND WE
KNOW WHAT YOU ARE PLANNING TO DO
IF YOU REALLY GET A STRANGLEHOLD
ON POWER.
WE WILL STOP YOU AT T